[Music]
tonight Demario he came to say a lot how
did you think he would be in recent
thought you're gonna say am I surprised
how he threw himself under the bus I
mean I really thought that he would come
in and be very contrite apologetic maybe
even a little quiet he was anything but
was that a good decision
no it was not a good decision and I
don't love revisionist history I don't
like when people come back on the show
and kind of make up how things went and
and so I didn't love it but that's
tomorrow he's such a character you think
our redemption will happen for him we're
gonna sit down with them it's not in it
I don't think it'll be just part of the
reunion show I'm gonna sit down go to
Mario and Koran as part of a sit-down
talk with the two of them and I don't
know I don't you know honestly after
tonight I don't know how that dialogue
is gonna go I thought I had an idea
before tonight but I also thought we'd
have a better moment than we had tonight
how would you describe the way he was in
a few words bad choices just bad choices
tonight he cussed a lot and me I don't
know he was just I don't know maybe
that's his defense mechanism I don't
know but he was I just knew it I didn't
see him going that direction I was very
surprised
[Music]